it's no secret that Maddie Ziegler was
Abby Lee Miller's favorite dancer on
Dance Moms Maddie was nearly always on
top of the pyramid which caused tension
to form within the group
keep watching to find out why Maddie was
Abby's go-to soloist week after week
[Music]
there's something about Maddie Ziegler
that always caught Abby Lee Miller's eye
Abby saw something special in her and
wasn't afraid to put her on a pedestal
although her favoritism often landed her
in the hot seat Abby just didn't care
there are so many reasons why Abby
praised Maddie above all her other
dancers and has something to do with her
natural charisma it was perfect when
Annie dances she owns the room and
that's what a competitive dancer teacher
looks for but this isn't to say that the
other girls weren't killing their
performances week after week but rather
that Maddie wasn't afraid to outshine
the other dancers to get to the top of
the pyramid Maddie and Abby go way back
and she's been pushing Maddie to shine
for as long as she's been able to walk
so it goes without saying that she broke
out of her shell a long time ago Maddie
was used to dancing for national
audiences and winning titles while some
of the other girls were still getting
used to competitive dance
I still think you have work to do after
years of dancing under Abby's guidance
her other students started to break out
of their shells as well and when they
did Abby never failed to issue praise
sure she boasted about Maddie being
top-tier but she was only rewarding her
for her hard work and keep in mind that
Abby was quick to switch things up when
Maddie failed to impress her Maddie
might have gotten used to the spotlight
but she was never in love with it more
often than not she felt pressured to be
the best and took it to heart when she
didn't win during an interview with
lifetime Maddie reminded us of the time
when Abby didn't give her a solo for
three weeks in a row
despite her spending nearly every waking
hour in the studio when it comes down to
it Abby wasn't giving Maddie handouts
she was giving praise when praise was
due three weeks without a solo might not
have seems like a big deal to the other
girls who sometimes only had three solos
per season but to Maddie
it meant everything and it didn't go
unnoticed for long on top of having
charisma and confidence maddie also had
a killer work ethic despite barely being
ten years old when she first appeared on
Dance Moms Maddie never failed to put in
the extra hours dancing was literally
her entire life and Abby saw how much
time and effort Maddie put in every
single day it's totally understandable
that Chloe Nia and the other girls
couldn't dedicate as much time to dance
as Maddie could her mother Melissa did
work at Abby's studio after all but
Abby's favoritism went beyond that in
the end Maddie was naturally talented
and driven she could learn new dances in
minutes which gave her extra time to
perfect routines before performing them
but this wasn't the case for everyone
and since the girls had little to no
time to learn their dance routines
before executing them on stage it was
crucial that they catch on quick and
let's face it that's not an easy thing
to do with a natural talent dedication
and charisma in the bag Maddie was
already outshining the other students
but on top of all that Maddie was a
champ at taking feedback and making
corrections
instead of taking Abby's critiques
personally Maddie's strived to perfect
her routines to make her dance teacher
proud by now we're all well aware that
Abby Lee Miller has zero patience
she doesn't want excuses she doesn't
care for laziness and she definitely
doesn't have time for tears despite
having her fair share of tearful moments
Maddy was able to take full constructive
criticism and come back in full swing so
she didn't get on Abby's bad side all
too often which probably contributed to
her being Abby's number one but if
there's one thing that made Maddie
special in Abby's eyes it was her
emotional performances Maddie wasn't
just dancing on stage she was telling
the story with her facial expressions
and body movements Maddie would go on
stage and so every aspect of herself
making her performance unforgettable and
moving to say that she had a star
quality would be an understatement and
Abby wasn't about to let it go to waste
she pushed Maddie harder than everyone
and in return
Maddie worked harder than the other
dancers while some people were quick to
say that Abby favors Maddie because of
their family history that's simply not
true because of that were the case Abby
wouldn't have been so hard on Mackenzie
Ziegler Kenzie spent most of her time on
Dance Moms being compared to her older
sister which wasn't an easy act to
follow
overall it's safe to say that Maddie was
Abby's favorites because she was the
greatest and this would later be proven
when Maddie attracted the attention of
the world famous singer SIA
when Maddie was only 11 years old SIA
personally messaged her own Twitter
asking her to play her in a music video
Maddie would go on to star and Sia's
chandelier video which garnered millions
of views and SIA liked her performance
so much that she pretty much made her
the face of her on-screen personality
the fact that one of Abby's dancers was
a worldwide phenomenon made her that
much more special in her dance teachers
book and how could it not her favorite
student and family friend was making it
big Abby has made it clear that the
Ziegler sisters a portion of their
success to her dance studio after all
SIA would probably never have messaged
Maddie if it hadn't been for Dance Moms
but while there is truth to that
statement Maddie is a remarkable dancer
who has that star quality that everyone
is looking for so she probably would
have made it
Nerone eventually there isn't one simple
reason as to why Maddie is Abby's
favorite but rather a collection of
reasons in the end
Maddie's drive talents passion
dedication and charisma is what led her
to being on top of the pyramid week
after week the life on the top isn't
always what it seems and staying on top
is even harder than getting there so
according to Maddie being on Dance Moms
was one of the most stressful times in
her young life in the end Maddie is
happy that Dance Moms happened but she's
also happy that it's over so why do you
think Maddie was Abby's favorite dancer
let us know in the comments section
below and while you're at it tell us
which Dance Moms personality was your
favorite and why give this video a big
thumbs up if you love Dance Moms and
don't forget to subscribe to the things
for more videos like this one thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]